معنا من غزه مراسله الجزيره
من التفاصيل والمعلومات حول ما جرى في غزه
في الساعتين الاخيرهتين لاسيما استهداف
الشقه السكنيه في مدينه حماه في خان يونس
حسن حسم الامر سرايا القدس اعلنت قبل قليل
ونعت الشهيد القائد المجاهد علي غالي ابو
محمد عضو المجلس العسكري ومسؤول الوحده
الصاروخيه في سرايا القدس وقالت انه ارتقى
في عمليه اغتيال اسرائيليه جديده على غزه
فجر هذا اليوم اذا ما حدث في الشقه
السكنيه في خان يونس في مدينه حمد جنوب
قطاع غزه هو عمليه اغتيال اسرائيليه جديده
لقائد عسكري جديد في سرايا القدس الجناح
العسكري لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي الحديث هنا
عن قائد بارز هو عظم مجلس عسكري وايضا هو
قائد وحده صاروخيه في سرايا قائد الوحده
الصاروخيه في سرايا القدس في قطاع غزه
قائد بارز قائد كبير هو مسؤول عن اطلاق
جميع الصواريخ التي اطلقت على
مناطق غلاف غزه وجنوب اسرائيل